um why don't we talk to
um oh I don't know I mean maybe uh
let's try
Marcos from Florida Marcos you're on the
air
hello
can you hear me you sound like you're
underwater we can hear you but you sound
like you're underwater
I'm sorry okay
um I don't know if it's better now but
it is I just want to say yeah I'm a fan
and uh I enjoy your show I was gonna ask
you about Trump's uh talking about the
Deep State yeah and
and it's like blaming the Deep state for
everything that's wrong
but it was during his presidency so does
that mean he was not in charge is he
saying he was just a puppet right
no you're making a very good point which
is I mean listen so first of all what
Marcos is referring to is that during an
interview with Mark Levin this week
Trump blamed the Deep state for trying
to remove him from Office through the
FBI investigation deep state is just
another Shadow government conspiracy
that someone else is really in control
sometimes it's the Jews could be Bill
Gates could be the bilderbergs the
Illuminati the trilateral commission
whatever
um it's it's fascinating for you to
frame it in these terms Marcos because
if indeed the Deep state
was in charge at the time it means Trump
really was not in charge and at the same
time if Trump was in charge then why is
it that he wasn't able to take control
of the deep State and who is in the Deep
State because it was his government of
course and it's all completely
incoherent and you're absolutely right
to point it out
no man Marcos we're losing you you're
going underwater more so I'm going to
let you go it's quite a connection uh
but I do appreciate you
um calling in today and it was really
really great speaking with you that's
going to do it for calls today folks we
will take calls again and next Tuesday
we have the David packman show viewer
Town Hall at 6 PM eastern time during
which we will be wide opening the
Discord lines and anybody who wants to
and can call in let's take a quick break
and we will keep going with the Friday
show